[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Katrina
is in Boston Mass hi Katrina what's up
hi Dave hi Ken thanks for taking my call
I am a new listener to your show and I
am just kicking myself for not listening
earlier I feel like I've never really
learned to adult when it comes to my
finances so I have a lot to learn um I
am a 45-year-old single mom by choice
that means I decided to have my children
on my own using a spermed donor and I
say that so you know I'm totally
financially responsible for my two kids
they just turned one and three their
little babies um and I'm really feeling
anxious about our financial future and
I'm just a little bit paralyzed about
what my next step should be um I have a
chunk of money in savings and I don't
know if I should pay off my mortgage
what's a
chunk um about I have about 250,000 in
savings of the kids right yeah it's a
good chunk they they each have about
eight grand in their in their accounts
as well okay um and how much do you make
a you have about 145 okay and what other
what debts other than your mortgage do
you have none just my mortgage I just
got a payoff quote on it because I have
a feeling you're going to tell me to pay
off
off it's 97 or 98 it's not much
but here's my
complications um I I bought my house a
few years ago from my father um I bought
it for 150 and it's a great deal at the
time it was probably worth 350 now I
think it's about worth 650 um but it's
falling apart and it also came with two
little rental units so the whole thing
together is probably sell for around 650
and everything is kind of old and
falling apart um I'm constantly putting
money into to fix things um never mind
trying to get ahead on some of the
repairs that I know will need to come
soon um the other complication I have is
that I have a very long commute to work
I'm I'm I'm high school teacher uh high
school vice principal um and I spend
between three and four hours a day
commuting right now so my kids are in I
know my kids are in daycare it's fine I
spend an absolute Fortune to you know
pay people to take care of my kids for
me so I know at some point in the next
few years I'm either going have to get a
new job which I don't want to do or buy
a new home that's closer to work so I
just don't know what to do with my money
and how to set myself up for success in
five years where did the 250 come
from just my savings your Frugal you
know amazing uh I guess yeah really I
mean you lived on $250,000 less than you
made over a period of some
years that's impressive well I'm 45 45
and I never had you're not 85 you just I
mean this is amazing you did great
receive the compliment you rock Katrina
you did great man I would sell the house
I would sell your house today yeah and
move closer to the district and pay cash
oh I okay I can't sell the house because
it's a family house that we are very
attached to who's
we me and my parents I'm not attached to
it it's a house allowed me to have the
kids that I would not have been able to
have when I was renting an apartment in
Boston you know so
it served its purpose and it's a house
you sell it even with the rental unit I
would sell it the chances of me
commuting 3 hours a day is precisely
zero for more than 10 days that's going
to kill you it's going to suck you have
you're more obligated to this house than
you are spending time with your
children oh I know but it I know I sell
the
house okay it's a stupid house oh my go
life is too short Comm if you gave your
children a gift that at first was a
blessing and later became a curse
because they didn't want you to feel bad
you didn't give them a
gift and you wouldn't do that to your
kids and your dad didn't do that to you
sell the house it's a house